AAA FUCK YOU!
What the fuck!
Okay, fuck off!
Hi.
Fuck.
OH GOD
GAH FUCK
AH FUCK.
The basis of ALL humor on YouTube,
If you want to be a good YouTuber
You gotta learn how to handle your balls.
They're gonna fudge me over so good...
Not good! Not in a good way!
Don't take that out of context.
[unless you want to...]
*feels like he just touched a boob*
[Mark is shocked and pulls his hand back in fear.]
'Oh My...'
And then give her more...
sugar- (cocaine)
I'm still trying!
My innocence is... [cough] is very delicate right now! I need to- I need to cherish it as much as I can...
YOU WANNA MESS WITH ME!
HUUUUH!??
DON'T MIND MY PRE-PUBESCENT CRACKING VOICE!
I'm very brave and manly!
AHH FUCK YOU.
TITS. I MEAN FUDGE. I MEAN COCK. AHH FUCK!!
I mean all things considered
Especially the scientist that accidentally fed me -
OOOOOOOHHHHHHH !
IT'S YOUR TIME
I'm sorry....
That actually kinda feels bad, but oh well!
What happens if I stick my whole head in here!?
OH
IT'S TERRIFYING
OH MY GOD
AHHHHHHHHHHH -
*chuckle*
There's Mark's Magnum Dong!
Ahhh - I dropped
my MAGNUM condom
from my MAGNUM Dong...
HEHEHEHE
Sorry.
I'm immature.
'When will the minions learn that I have the power'
OH - I just have to start
🎵 OVER AGAIN 🎵
🎵 UNTIL I LOSE MY MIND 🎵
🎵 EVERYTHING IS INSANE IN MY BRAIN, YES! 🎵
"Hey, Mark. I live in L.A. too. How do you like living -"
[Low Alien-like electronic voice]
HEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEERE
[Bass drop]
Pooperstamper! RRU! RRU! RRU! RRU!
[Hacked a hairball] I seem to have forgotten how to tranquilize someone
Because! I'm pretty sure I just straight up murdered her. SOMEHOW with a syringe.
There was so much super herpes and HIV on this syringe. It just killed her instantaneously.
Looong ass level with looong ass problems
Sigh. Hashtag long ASS problems
"I could've been an engineer!" thought Mark, with joyful tears that he didn't take that dark route.
YEEEAH! OHH it's Chica Bica! Oh my goodness!
*GASP* Sigh~ It makes me feel so much BETTER!
(Giggling fit) Haha ya. Yes, I'm going to PornHub right now, on my phone!
But not- not- sshh- everybody shut up! I'm just looking up myself... (DON'T JUDGE ME)
(muffled) ...On PornHub...
Shut up! (YOU'RE JUDGING!)
[Hysterical laughter at his own not-actually-porn videos]
Oh my God, Someone- someone posted like,  something from Mario Maker and it says: "The Sexy Interracial Man Releases His Anger"
(Giggling fit) And there's more stuff like that on there...
Alright, alright, alriiiiiight~!
Oh shit, oh shit, oh FUUUCK!
Also, if you hear any gross, crunching sounds that's because Chica's in the room and she's currently chewing on a BONE
So, ignore that! And ig- definitely focus on the gross crunching that is happening as I'm eating all these ants-
In an eco-terrorist disaster that's gonna cause a rip in the fabric of time.
And that's a snail. Goddamn.
*inhale laugh* "Interracial Sexy Goof Shoves Bread Into His Fury Hole" [Laughter]
This was when I was a young lad! Very young and full of hope!
And this is me mid-puberty. Boy! What a difference that time in my life made for me!
Aren't I glad I went through that without any (giggling fit) horrible defiguring ailments.
Anyway!
F*CK THIS SH*T IM OUT!!!
Ha ha! Ha I- got- Oh, god. Oh, God!
OHH GOD, NO! OHH.
(At smaller snake) AT LEAST YOU DIED! AAAAGH fuck!
You're all Terminators! Ohh, STOP it!
Ah! You're so weird!
♥ Hi Senpai! You're not weird! You could never be weird! ♥
♥ Oh my God, that's amazing! You went right through door, I looove you ♥
Uugh, "Get To Work"- Ah fuck you
(slow motion) Ah fuck you
COMPUTER: -your day with an addictive liquid stimulant
*screams with excitement* Ha! Ha! Aaah!
Uuh. Uh. Uh.
[Sounds of progress]
Ah ha! Okay
Yaaaay!
Business!
[gibberish]
Chica! Stop messing with everything!
Chica! Stop!
(to Chica) Do not. That's a bad girl you go lay down
You lay down. You lay down. Stay.
Have to put on the Dad Pants™ every once in a while with Chica
(At Chica) You stay! You stay there! You stay right there!
...Good. Stay.
[Chica gives Mark large sad puppy eyes]
Don't give me that look. You stay.
Thanks for watching. All the videos in this compilation are available in the description, so check 'em out.
AND! If you'd like to see more in the future PLEASE leave a Like to let me know!
If you enjoyed this video and would like to see more on a daily basis, please subscribe today!
Or, if you're already subscribed, share this video with a friend
Thanks again for watching. And I'll see YOU... in the next video.
Bye bye!